[Musique]
le 21 avril 2011 la police découvre les
corps d'agnès dupont de ligonnès et de
ses quatre enfants enterrés sous la
terrasse du jardin familial à nantes
tous ont été droguées puis tué d'au
moins deux balles dans la tête
les enquêteurs parleront d'une exécution
méthodique comme vous le savez les corps
ont été exhumés dans le jardin de la
famille sous la terrasse de la maison le
corps de thomas seuls les quatre autres
corps plus ceux des deux chiens dans une
fosse creusée d'environ 70 cm de
profondeur est d'environ trois mètres de
long les corps étant les uns et les
autres
superposer les soupçons vont alors se
pencher vers le père xavier dupont de
ligonnès qui vingt jours avant la
découverte des corps par la police à
acheter dans plusieurs magasins du
ciment une bêche et une houe et surtout
quatre sacs de 10 kg de chaux
selon les enquêteurs xavier dupont de
ligonnès aurait tué dans la nuit du 3 au
4 avril son épouse agnès et trois de ses
enfants leur demain il demandera son
autre fils thomas de rentrer à nantes
il sera probablement tué cette nuit là
une semaine après les probables
assassinats des courriers sont envoyés à
des membres de la famille dans lesquels
xavier dupont de ligonnès explique être
un agent secret américain et qui va
prochainement être explique très vers
les états unis
le soir du meurtre il est d'ailleurs un
message téléphonique à sa soeur
christine
[Musique]
dans les preuves accablantes un mandat
d'arrêt international est émis à son
encontre le 10 mai 2011
le père de famille sera vue de manière
certaine pour la dernière fois le 14
avril 2011
filmée devant un distributeur de billets
retirant la somme de 30 euros à
roquebrune-sur-argens dans le var
dès lors les fausses pistes vont se
multiplier de la découverte d'ossements
à fréjus dans le var qui ne seront
finalement pas ceux du fugitif en avril
2015 en passant par le courrier reçu par
l' agence france-presse
en juillet 2015 signé xavier dupont de
ligonnès dans lequel est écrit je suis
toujours vivant daté du 11 juillet 2015
[Musique]
le 9 janvier 2018 une opération de
police est menée dans un monastère à
roquebrune-sur-argens
suite au signalement fait par des
fidèles du monastère fin 2017 déclarant
avoir vu un moine ressemblant
xavier dupont de ligonnès derniers
rebondissements l'arrestation vendredi
11 octobre 2010 9 à glasgow en écosse
d'un homme qui finalement ne sera pas
dupont de ligonnès au fur et à mesure de
la faire les enquêteurs décrivant une
personnalité complexe pour un homme qui
débutera son initiation au tir en
décembre 2010 avec un pistolet puis une
carabine 22 long rifle hérité de son
père est décrit par certains témoins
équipé d'un silencieux
selon les enquêteurs c'est avec cette
arme que de ligonnès aurait assassiné sa
femme et ses quatre enfants arthur 21
ans thomas 18 ans anne 16 ans et benoît
13 ans
[Musique]
oh